foreign
being a cloud developer in 2023 it's a
truly remarkable experience but while
giving you all these exciting
opportunities the fast evolving
technology landscape in the increasing
number of cloud services have also led
to unprecedented levels of complexity at
Google Cloud we're committed to helping
developers we want to make your life
better by giving you a new way to Cloud
that is fast easy and secure
so rather than burdening our developers
with an ever-growing set of
responsibilities in the software
lifecycle by shifting left
we want to make your life easier by
shifting down providing integrated
assistance pre-configured automations
and out of the box security through our
platform and through our managed
services and today I'm happy to announce
the general availability of jump start
solutions a new way to get you started
with Google cloud with jumpstart
Solutions you can quickly deploy
pre-built application and infrastructure
best practices into your Google Cloud
account
and can learn inside an interactive
environment right in the Google Cloud
Web console today we have 14 jumpstart
Solutions available in the Google Cloud
console for you to pick from all of
these Solutions are open source you can
play around with it customize it use it
as a starting point to build your own
application you can also go check them
out via the link here or find them in
the Google Cloud console
talking about AI duet AI as you may all
know is the product that's designed to
transform the way everyone works in
Google Cloud we're now expanding the
duet AI preview adding duet AI
capabilities across a wide range of
Google Cloud products
and assisting more Cloud users for
developers we introduce many new
features to the dwet AI preview in
addition to features like code
completion and code generation you'll
Now find duet AI chat assistance in many
Google Cloud products we've also
introduced smart actions which allow you
to perform contextual AI powered actions
like code explanation and test
generation
and to support your compliance needs in
terms of licensing requirements duetai
provides Source citations now duet AI
today supports more than 20 programming
languages and thanks to Cloud code you
can also use duet AI in many popular
Ides duet AI is also available in apogee
API management now in apogee duetai can
do things like help developers build API
specifications from simple natural
language prompts if you'd like to learn
more about all the exciting developer
capabilities of duet AI please visit
this duet AI webpage cloud.google.com
duet-ai
another aspect of enabling different
application components to work together
what we call integration today we are
extending our integration services to
include application integration a new
platform designed to help you automate
app to app Communications across both
Google cloud and third-party software
without the need for complex coding or
configurations in recent years you know
as an example with the rising trend of
remote and hybrid working companies are
hiring more developers that are widely
dispersed which can lead to increasing
security concerns it can also cause slow
developer onboarding and reduce
development productivity now to help
address these challenges we introduced
Cloud workstations last year at Dex
which successfully went into GA recently
besides Cloud workstations
another example of us shifting security
down is around software supply chain
security to help Google Cloud customers
who are using many of our partner
Solutions in their software delivery
cycle today I'm thrilled to announce our
expanded partnership with gitlab now let
me welcome David DeSanto Chief product
officer from gitlab onto the stage David
gitlab and Google Cloud are partnering
to provide a seamless devsecops
experience allowing you to bring
software supply chain security to the
Forefront of how you build software this
partnership delivers an end-to-end
application development experience that
is deeply integrated together providing
you Best in Class reliability efficiency
and security end to end we're going to
continue to work on this and if you want
to know more please sign up you can scan
and you'll get updates thank you all and
back you Gabe thank you again to uh you
know for everyone for attending this
session in this AI driven world Google
cloud is committed to helping Developers
by shifting down instead of Shifting
left we want to give you a new way to
Cloud that is fast easy and secure
[Music]